Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu das Podcast UFO. Ich bin Stefan Titzel und mir gegen Übersitz Florentin Will. Hallo, ich bin Florentin. Ich freue mich sehr auf die heutige Folge mit dir, Stefan Titzel, und danke an Sebastian für das fantastische Intro. Heute wollen wir ein paar lustige Themen besprechen,, da bleibt uns ja fast nichts mehr übrig. Ich glaube, dem ist nichts viel Sinn zuzufügen. Nee, gar nicht. Wurde schon bedankt für das Intro. Uns bleiben eigentlich nur die Abmoderationen. Du, du, du, du, du, du, du. Ach nee, da gibt es auch ein Outro von Sebastian. Vielen Dank an Sebastian für dieses freche Intro. Ja, er hat er selber bei sich bedankt. Warum ist Stefan der Franzose und ich nicht? Warum hast du eine Akzentu... Das richtest du an mit deinem Intro, Sebastian. Letzte Woche irgendwie österreichisch hier geballert, Hamburgerisch haben wir schon gehört. Verleitet vorhin bitte nicht mit euren Intros zu Akzenten. Auf gar keinen Fall. Das wäre meine einzige Bitte. Ansonsten schickt vielleicht die Intros ein. Meine Bitte ist kurz. Also das sind die beiden Parameter, die ihr erfüllen müsst. Ihr müsst aber ansonsten passen. Vielen, vielen Dank auf jeden Fall. Wir haben nämlich eine Frage bekommen von einem Hörer, einer Hörerin, ob wir Bock haben auf ein Intro, ein Jingle. Und ich wollte ja sagen, ja klar, immer, aber es klang wie eine professionelle Anfrage. Ich glaube, es handelt sich um richtige Komponistinnen, richtigen Komponisten. Wahrscheinlich haben uns auch schon große Komponisten ihren Jingle-Vorschlag geschickt. Und Rechnungen. Senden das einfach so weg, nebenbei einfach so. Danke an Wolfgang Amadeus, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank an Michael Giacchino. Vielen Dank. Und dann haben wir irgendwo Rechnungen, ballen sich, aber treib bitte keinen Keil zwischen uns, das wäre nett. Bitte treib keinen Keil zwischen uns. Stefan ist ohnehin, er entfernt sich immer weiter von mir, er hat immer noch obskure Hobbys. Kannst du mir folgen? Ja. Folg mir auf mein Bötchen, auf mein Segelbötchen, wir stechen in hoher See. Was ist dein aktuelles Hobby die Woche, hast du angefangen zu morsen oder was, Stefan nur noch so wie so Hobbyfunker unterwegs, waren Morse-Code-Leute eigentlich die damaligen DJs, die auch immer so an einem Kopfhörer an einer Seite und dann so einfach Freestyle. Hey, kann ich mir das Wort Wiederauferstehung wünschen? Ja, du, passt gerade nicht so zur Stimmung, aber ich glaube, ich kriege es irgendwie rein, wenn ich da so ein bisschen meinen eigenen Flavor gebe. Okay, pass auf. Das Wort Met wäre auch okay. Okay. Und das Dorf. Hey, ho, hey, ho, das mittelalterliche Dorf ist mitten dabei. Hey, ho, ich glaube auch, dass da, weil damals, das finde ich immer das Beste, so in diesen U-Boot-Filmen, wo dann irgendwie das Wasser dringt ein und alle bieb, bieb und schrecklich und so. Und es gibt immer diesen einen Morsegei, der einfach immer nur am Pult sitzt, am Sonar, und Platz Nummer eins, Sie haben Angst vor Wassermienen. Gut, das war unsere Rubrik für diese Woche. Wir gehen heute schnell durch. Ja, wir gehen schnell durch. Wir haben heute eine Menge auf dem Zettel. Zum einen viele Fragen von euch bezüglich, mich gerichtet an den Grossmeister, Grossmeister Stefan. Morsemann Stefan. Morsemann Stefan, denn ich bin so drin im Schachdrama, ich kann es, ich halte es nicht aus.
Kannst du es selber schon nicht mehr ertragen.
Es ist die coolste Geschichte, also es ist Twists and Turns auf allen Seiten, um mich kurz nochmal abzuholen. Was ist passiert? Der Springer ist plötzlich drei Felder nach vorne gegangen, anstatt drei nach vorne und eins nach rechts. Das war jetzt der Skandal im Schach oder was? Das grosse Schachdrama, Magnus Carlsen beschuldigt den 19-jährigen Hans-Siemann des Cheatings.
Und das nimmt immer obskurere Züge an, immer mehr Leute schalten sich ein und was ich ja als großer Mathe-Fan, bin ein großer Fan der Mathematik und was ich jetzt gerade so toll finde, dass zum ersten Mal jetzt Statistiker und Mathematiker, die glaube ich was ganz anderes sind, wurde mir gesagt, aber für mich ist es grob eine Schublade, bin ich ganz ehrlich, die schalten sich jetzt ein und haben seit langer Zeit mal wieder einen richtig geilen Job. Endlich. Denn wann haben Statistiker nochmal so ein richtig geiles Drama am Start? Die warten in ihrer Statistikerhöhle, bis endlich wieder dieses Statistikerzeichen in die Luft geworfen wird, in die Wolken. Und dann rutschen sie durch die Stange runter und werfen sich ihren Statistikeranzug um und endlich mal Statistik mobil. Ein Statistiker-Notfall. Ja. Wirklich, ich rufe die Notfall-Hotline an und dann war da jemand, der aus so einem Nosferatu-Schlaf so aufgewacht ist. Genau, sehr gruft. Und dann so, oh ja, und die ganze Fleder mal so. Das ist auch wie, hier hat das seit Jahren niemand mehr angerufen. Ein ganz altes Telefon. Wir brauchen die Hilfe, 0800 Pareto, 0800 Pareto. Und dann kommen sie alle zusammen, die Statistiker. Ja, weil da wird nämlich jetzt nach Anomalien gesucht, sowohl, weil man hat ja im Schacht diese Elo, heisst, wenn man gegen gute Gegner gewinnt, bekommt man mehr Punkte, als wenn man gegen gleich gute Gegner gewinnt. Also so ändert sich halt, oh, haben wir einen Notfall? Haben wir einen Notfall bekommen? Ja, der Podcaster-Alarm wurde ausgerufen. Podcaster-Alarm. 0800 Kondensmikrofon und wir müssen los. Sorry, wir müssen leider direkt los. 0800 Clark wurde angerufen. Aber ja, das muss ich schon sagen, das ist super spannend und da wird es gerade mit so grossen Excel-Tabellen, die man sich shared und herumschickt, wird nach Anomalien gesucht bei den Spielen von Hans Niemann. Ja, es ist spannend, weil Schachspieler wollen gut spielen, aber wenn sie zu gut spielen und zu nah am perfekten Ergebnis des Schachcomputers sind, dann sind sie verdächtig. Dann sind sie super verdächtig. Das heißt, ist nicht vielleicht die Zukunft des perfekten Schachspielers die, dass man zwar schon gut spielt, aber sich denkt, ah, wenn ich das jetzt mache, das hätte der Computer gemacht, dann bin ich verdächtig. Man muss also so immer unterm Radar fliegen und nicht zu, das ist wie wenn du mit einem Kind Fussball spielst. Natürlich willst du gewinnen, klar, du wirst auch gewinnen, aber du willst nicht mit mehr als drei Toren gewinnen. Du willst so gewinnen, dass das Kind danach nicht traurig zur Mutter rennt und sagt, der Mann hat mich schon wieder abgezogen. Richtig, du willst gewinnen, aber nicht dominieren. Du denkst dir so, okay, ich lasse sie so drei Tore hinter mir und dann kriegen wir das schon hin einigermaßen. Man kann das Kind auch gewinnen lassen, Florian, das habe ich schon ein paar Mal gesagt. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Nein, die müssen ja Motivation haben, besser zu werden. Ja, aber man lässt auch Kinder gewinnen. Wenn du ein Kind gewinnen lässt, sagt das, boah, habe ich, fertig, Hobby beendet, kein Problem. Nein, die müssen kämpfen, kämpfen, kämpfen. Kinder wissen tief im Herzen, dass sie gewonnen lassen wurden. Wirklich? Ja, weiß ich nicht. Ist nicht meine Erfahrung, ehrlich gesagt. Wie so ein stolzer Hahn, stolzieren die Wochen dann noch rum und sagen, nee, nee, nee, ich hab dich besiegt. Und du so, ja, nur weil ich dich hab gewinnen. Dann war ich ein anderes Kind, weil ich hab mal mein anderes Beispiel, ich hab mal meinen Vater erwischt, wie er für Ostern ganz viele Eier gekocht hat, um die Nacht zu bemalen und am nächsten Tag die zu verstecken im Garten, die ganzen Eier. Er hat sie bemalt? Ja, so in Farbe eingelegt, weißt du, wie man das macht? Und dann habe ich immer so ein Osternest dann gesammelt. Und er hat die abends in der Küche halt für den nächsten Tag gekocht, damit er die ganzen im Garten verstecken konnte. Und ich habe das gesehen und habe gesagt, was machst du denn da? Und er hat gesagt, für morgen früh zum Frühstück, clever. Und ich habe gesagt, ah ja, okay, verstehe, wusste aber ab dem Moment, nee, das macht er, weil er der Osterhase ist. Dann ist für dich der Osterhase gestorben. Aber er hat mich quasi gewinnen lassen, immer noch quasi, immer in der Metafer zu bleiben, und ich habe das machen lassen mit mir. Du willst sagen, Kinder sind schlauer als man denkt? Kinder sind schlauer als Erwachsene, wie soll ich sagen. Okay, verstehe. Ich gehe all in heute. Aber es ist super spannend, und jetzt sucht man all den Extratabellen nach verschiedenen Anomalien, wie zum Beispiel, er war da zu gut. Was natürlich total spannend ist, weil er kann ja, also statistisch kannst du ja eine perfekte Partie haben. Why not? Es ist halt super unwahrscheinlich, aber es gewinnen auch Menschen im Lotto. Es passieren halt jeden Tag so viele Dinge, dass auch Wunder passieren, statistisch gesehen. Jeden Tag passieren eine Milliarde, sagen wir mal, eine Milliarde Dinge in deinem Tag passieren, Kleinigkeiten, eine Milliarde Dinge. Natürlich ist dabei was sehr Unwahrscheinliches. Soll das jetzt motivierend sein oder soll das jetzt ... In beide Richtungen. In welche Richtung?
Du kannst vom Blitz getroffen werden.
Klingt gut, aber du meinst statistisch, was genau meinst du jetzt? Ich meine, nimm dich in acht und freu dich schon mal auf die Zukunft. Also deine Instagram-Kachel ist, statistisch gesehen passieren jeden Tag Wunder. Das ist meine Tinder-Biografie und steht in meiner Küche hinten als Wandtattoo ganz groß. Als Tinder-Biografie ist nicht schlecht, ich bin auf Wunder angewiesen.
Ach so, okay. Statistisch gesehen passiert jeden Tag mal ein Wunder.
Aber das heißt, die gehen jetzt zu diesem Schachspieler und sagen,
sie haben aber zu gut gespielt und der, tja, das ist eine Anomalie, Herr Niemann.
Ja, für mich ist das eine Nomalie. Weil ich so gut bin. Weil ich so gut bin. Das könnt ihr gar nicht glauben, wie gut ich bin. Entweder wird man ihm jetzt vor, bestrogen zu haben oder so ein Pakt mit dem Teufel. Er hat so einen Pakt mit dem Schicksal. Haben Sie Ihre Seele verkauft? Definieren Sie Seele. Ich bin teilweise mit diversen Kräften im Kontakt, aber da möchte ich... Schau dirau dir mal die meisten Sochspieler an, die sehen so aus, hätten die ihre Seele verkauft. Am I right, am I right? Ich kenne niemanden. Doch, wir kennen ja den Gustavsson, der hat mich auch quasi in seinem Stream, nicht mich, aber die Diskussion nochmal auch eingeschätzt und da muss ich was zu mich zurücknehmen. Ich habe nämlich gesagt, es reichen ja zwei Züge aus auf diesem Level, um eine Partie zu entscheiden. Das stimmt weiterhin, aber es ist wohl sehr unwahrscheinlich. Und das kann ich ja nicht einschätzen, weil ich keine Erfahrung habe, weil ich nach meinem Wunderkind-Attestat sofort aufgehört habe zu spielen. aber in dem Moment, also es war sehr schwierig, die ganze Partie normal zu spielen, dann irgendwann aus dem Nichts einen Code gemorst zu bekommen, der dir sagt, Bauer nach E4, und dann wieder normal weiter zu spielen. Weil diese Züge kommen ja manchmal aus dem Nichts. Also es ist, glaube ich, er meint, es wäre sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass nur zwei Züge kommen. Hans Niemann, kometenhafter Aufstieg, spielt viel zu gut für sein Alter und seine Erfahrung.. Wir kommen übrigens beim Schachpodcast. Der Gegenüber, Stefan Tietze, ja, jugendlicher Heissporn, wird zwei Wochen, nachdem er die Steine in die Hand nimmt, sofort zum grössten Talent der Geschichte genannt. Hat da eigentlich mal jemand reingeguckt, was da vibriert hat? Können wir die Webcam noch mal sehen, was da bei Stephans
Züge beim grossen Zugzwang-Turnier
vibriert hat? Können wir da noch mal reingucken?
Der grösste Schachskandal des Jahres.
Finde ich gut. Sucht mal bitte bei Zugzwang
meine Partien raus und guckt mal,
was die für eine Genauigkeit haben. Weil alle
checken gerade die Engine-Zug
Correlation, also
inwiefern das ein Zug ist,
den ein Engine als Topzug vorschlägt.
Hans Niemann hat wirklich überdurchschnittlich viele
100-Prozent-Partien, aber inzwischen hat man auch
Das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen, also inwiefern das ein Zug ist, den ein Engine als Topzug vorschlägt.
Hans Niemann hat wirklich überdurchschnittlich viele hundert Prozent Partien, aber inzwischen hat man auch schon da wieder rausgefunden, das war auch irgendwie seltsam, weil da bei der Seite, wo das gemacht wurde, wurde entdeckt, dass die Topzüge verschiedener Engines, also verschiedener Schach-AIs benutzt wurden und die kann man alle zuschalten und manche AIs waren einfach von einem User, wo nachher rauskam, dass das ein Nutzername ist. Der hat verschiedenen Leuten, Großmeistern, so einen Datensatz geschickt an. Hier schaut mal, das ist sehr verdächtig, was der Niemand da macht. Kommt aber raus, dass bei dem Tressable, wo man das machen kann, wo man das untersuchen kann, er derjenige ist, der diese Engine hinzugefügt hat, wo die Niemand-Züge, die Topzüge waren. Also alles ist überspannend. Ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, der sich da halbwegs für begeistern kann, für Statistik oder für Stach. Nerdet euch da rein, das macht großen Spaß. Wie ist das eigentlich mit dem Publikum? Weil diese großen Topspieler spielen ja wahrscheinlich vor Publikum. Wenn ich jetzt im Publikum sitze und dann irgendwie stille, alle denken nach und ich so, B4, du Loser, auf B4! Was passiert dann? Ist dann die Partie ungültig, werde ich hinaus eskortiert? Wo fängt es dann an? Und wenn dann beim Fussballstadion jemand ruft, ja, passt doch nach vorne! Friedrichsen steht doch frei! Cheating. Es ist eigentlich Cheat. Schalke 04 wurde jetzt des Cheatings verdächtigt, weil auf der Tribüne jemand immer sagt, ah, Friedrichsen ist frei. Wenn ich im Schach cheaten wollen würde, ich würde Mama anrufen, der ihr so ein iPhone in die Hand geben, die spielt die Partie mit ihrer Chess-App irgendwie Schachmäuschen nach, Chess-Mom nach und dann brüllt die einfach Däume auf acht! Acht! So eine riesige Schall. Die berühmten Jazz-Moms, die ja jeder kennt, die ja jeder hat, mit diesen grossen Aldi-Taschen, wo dann auch so ein Picknick-Kram mitgebracht wurde und so und die ganzen Moms, die trinken Mimosas und stehen am Spielfeld dran und rufen E-Fier! Bernd! Und wenn du dann den Zug hörst, dann musst du den aktiv nicht machen, weil sonst wird es wie Cheating aussieht. Es ist schwierig. Kannst du nicht so ein Schild hochheben, auf dem E5 steht oder so und dann sagst du, ja, das ist das ist halt mein Geburtsdatum oder so, da kann man doch was machen. E5. Ja, ich glaube, ich glaube, da sind die Tore zweit offen und ranger. Ich glaube, Leute werden angewiesen, nichts zu tun. Vielleicht wird dann so eine Partie sogar nicht gewertet, wenn jemand da laut was reinruft. Wäre aber auch ein dummes Cheating. Ja, vor allem dann kannst du die Partie ja beenden, wenn es schlecht läuft für deinen Spieler. Ich finde es überspannend. Schwierig. Es ist auch immer noch ein großes Rätsel, wie es überhaupt passieren kann. Es wurden ein paar Dinge angekündigt. Chess.com hat angekündigt. Jetzt wird es ernst, Leute. E-Mail, fuck. Chess.fucking.com. Das wird ein hartes Jahr noch, Leute. Jetzt wurden die Maßnahmen angekündigt. Hat angekündigt, E-Mail-Korrespondenzen zu veröffentlichen. Und ich bin dahinter. Als Investigativjournalist klemme ich mich dahinter. Wer hat die Rechte an dem Skandal? Ab wann kann man die Rechte an diesem Skandal kaufen? Ich denke an Serie, ich denke an Graphic No novel, ich denk an Musical. Chess, das Musical, das ist doch perfekt. Sowas junger, aufsteigender Schachspieler, alle sagen, der cheatet. Vielleicht hat er früher mal gecheatet, darüber ist er jetzt weg. Wer glaubt ihm noch, wer nicht, jetzt ist grosses Spiel, alles kaputt. Das ist doch ein perfektes Musical. Ich denk tatsächlich wirklich eher an Film. Und das find ich total geil. Oder vielleicht so ein Wasserrutschenpark. So ein grosser Wasserpark mit Schach. Erst der Film und dann würde ich diese Parkidee verfolgen. Und eine Achterbahn. Wie gesagt, aber was für ein Franchise ist das, was da noch rein existiert? Ja, so eine Restaurantkette. Dass du halt so eine komplette Hans-Niemann-Restaurant-Kette machst, wo die Leute dann so Pommes in Form von Schachfiguren haben oder sowas in der Richtung. Oder dann gibt es auch die Schweizer Öffnung oder so, das dann mit Käse oder sowas in der Richtung. Da kann man viel machen. Ich glaube wirklich so ein neues Wendy's, ein neues Chuck E. Cheese, einfach wirklich. Okay. Ihr kommt darauf zurück, also wir kommen darauf zurück. Okay. Aber wir rufen uns, wir rufen dieses Mal auf jeden Fall an. Alles klar, das wäre nett. Weil die haben es das letzte Mal schon gesagt. Ich weiß. Sie haben es das letzte Mal schon gesagt, bei dem Relotius-Raurant, haben sie gesagt, dass sie auch anrufen, aber da kam dann, also vielleicht auf der Mailbox. Aber das war rückblickend auch eine bescheuerte Idee. Das war rückblickend auch eine bescheuerte Idee, aber gerne zwischen 14 und 18 Uhr. Vor allem, es war vor dem Skandal. Ja, das war merkwürdig. Kennen Sie den Journalisten Relotius? Nein? Okay, pass auf. Okay, pass auf, wir haben hier eine folgende Restaurantidee. Ja, da kam jetzt ja der Film raus von Bulli. Wir haben damals ja bei Filmfights überlegt, welches Ereignis des Jahres sollte filmen werden. Oh, aber meine Idee wurde auch verfilmt. Deine Idee wurde auch verfilmt. Und Antis Idee, jetzt Relotius, wurde auch verfilmt. Was war deine bescheuerte Kackidee? Ja, das Dota-Turnier, das E-Sport-Dota-Turnier wurde nicht verfilmt. Wow, let's ... Oh, na ja ... Ist da was in der Mache, Stefan T. Schau mal, bei Paramount Plus kam jetzt die Serie Players raus, von den Leuten von American Bandle, über eine Gruppe wie OG. Ja, aber ich denke an die fähige Serie. Ja! Ja! So, aber auf jeden Fall, dein Film kam raus. Antjes Film kam jetzt auch aus. Alle drei wurden quasi was ausgemacht. Also guckt da noch mal die alten Filmfallsfolgen rein. Falls ihr struggelnde Drehbuchautoren seid, schaut noch mal in alte Folgen rein, vielleicht findet ihr das. Verfolgt viele Filmfallsfolgen und schaut euch das an. Da können wir auf jeden Fall noch was finden. Ja, jetzt kam ja der Film raus, Bulli, ich habe ihn nicht gesehen. Niemand. Niemand. Hans, niemand. Oh, schön. Niemand hat den Film gesehen, außer, glaube ich, ein paar Kritiker, die da rein mussten. Die, tut mir auch leid, die müssen in den Schott-Film gehen. War ja auch lange Filmkritiker, so ist es ja nicht. 2019. Im Filmfehlerforum. Ne, 2009, nee. Haben die aus den alten Freunden aus dem Filmfehlerforum eigentlich mal in alte Filmfights-Folgen reingeguckt? Ich denke ja an Filmfehlerforum und Filmfights-Crossover. Findest du, dass Filmfights und Filmfehlerforum ein Match sind? Ja, kann schon sein. Man könnte immer so eine richtige Pedantenfolge machen, so irgendwie grösste Fehler oder so und dann so wirklich Trivialität. Die Pedantenfolge, grösste Fehler, das ist im Filmfeilforum mit alles. Ja, nee, ich war da schon lange nicht mehr. Ich habe mich verabschiedet von dieser Pedanterie. Ich versuche wegzukommen davon. Ich versuche das Leben zu genießen. Oh, ich versuche hinzukommen. Das ist interessant, weil ich glaube, es gibt bei mir auch wieder eine Phase, wo ich wieder hinkomme. Ich versuche, von der Pedanterie wegzukommen, ich versuche, Dinge nicht zu zerreden, zu zerstückeln, sondern als Ganzes zu geniessen und zu erfahren. Aber wie klappt das? Nicht gut, nicht gut. Ich rede mir ein, dass Dinge vielleicht besser sind, als wir unbedingt sind. Aber was ich uns, man muss sich ja auch mal auf die Schulter klopfen, weil ich finde, wir arbeiten an uns. Wir nehmen uns Dinge vor, da passiert dann auch nichts. Nee, es sind leider bei uns immer so Pendelbewegungen, es ist immer so hin und her zwischen Pedanterie und tolerant und pedant und dann immer wieder hin und her.
Und es hat nicht so das Gefühl von so einer Entwicklung, es ist eher so ein Oszillieren.
Der Wille zählt ist der düsseligste, ist genau wie Dabeisein ist alles, der Wille zählt. Habe ich beides immer auch mal gesagt.
Der Wille ist das Letzte, was zählt.
Oft gross genickt, als jemand gesagt hat im Raum, aber nie, im Kopf immer Kopfgeschüttelt.
Jeder kann alles wollen, das ist nicht das Problem.
Ja, ich will mich verändern.
Okay, der Wille zählt, danke, fertig.
Der Wille zählt nicht.
Der Wille zählt gerade eben, der Wille zählt halt nicht.
Der Wille zählt halt eben nicht.
Das müsste eigentlich das Sprichwort sein.
Halt eben nicht.
Das ist unsere Instagram-Kachel.
Der Wille zählt halt eben nicht. Sondern Taten. Ja. Aber ich, also, weil Statistik ist in der Hinsicht auch ein mega spannendes Fach, weil du ja einfach wirklich nichts beweisen kannst. Am Ende steht der nicht, deswegen ist es glaube ich auch nicht Mathematik, jetzt große, große, steile These, aber weil am Ende kein klares Ergebnis rauskommt.
Wenn etwas statistisch, also natürlich kommt statistisch ein klares Ergebnis raus, aber die legale Schlussfolgerung ist ja weird.
Und dann gibt es dieses geile Gesetz, ich glaube es heißt Benfordisches Gesetz, Benford's Law, dass kleine Zahlen häufiger auftreten.
Das ist total spannend, denn wenn du in den Supermarkt gehst zum Beispiel und immer die erste Ziffer notierst, aller Preise, die da stehen, oder du guckst auf der Financial Times, die die Titelseite an und notierst dir von allen Zahlen, die du da siehst, immer die erste Zahl, müsste man ja eigentlich glauben, dass die Ziffern von eins bis neun gleichmässig 11,1 Prozent vertreten sind. Tatsächlich ist aber was auch immer, Prozent vertreten sind.
Tatsächlich ist aber die Eins zu 30 Prozent vertreten, dann wird es immer weniger.
Das ist irgendwie so eine Gesetzmäßigkeit, dass kleine Zahlen häufiger vorkommen.
Könnte ich jetzt erklären, lassen wir mal lieber sein.
Könnte ich auch nicht. Und das wird auch benutzt, um Betrugsfälle zum Beispiel nachzuschauen, ob Zahlenverteilungen
natürlich sind oder befälscht wurden.
Genau, wenn du bei den Steuern komischerweise immer auch gleichmäßig verteilte Zahlen hast
Das war es. ob Zahlenverteilungen natürlich sind oder befälscht wurden. Genau, wenn du bei den Steuern komischerweise immer auch gleichmäßig verteilte Zahlen hast oder halt die neun häufiger Vorkommnungen hast, die eins, ist es mittlerweile vor dem Gericht zugelassen, Benfords Law, eine statistische Erhebung. Und das ist als Beweismittel zugelassen. Das heißt, alle Fälscher, wenn ihr fälscht, müsst ihr euch trotzdem noch an Benfords Law halten. Genau, wenn ihr fälscht, daran halten. Aber dann die These, macht man ja dann nicht. Ja. Also wie? Zweite Krache, man macht es halt dann am Ende nicht. Macht man dann halt auch nicht. Aber nochmal ganz kurz zur Verständnisfrage. Wenn dieser Niemann jetzt eine 100% Übereinstimmung mit dem Schachcomputer hat, dann könnte er doch eigentlich auch einen Schachcomputer besiegen, oder nicht? Nein, das sind ja immer nur kleine Cherry-Picked Games, wo das war. Also nur sein bestes Spiel. Weil ich dachte, Schachcomputer sind so krass, dass sie Menschen gar nicht mehr ranlassen können. Nein, Schachcomputer sind viel besser in dem Spiel als Menschen. Auch nicht mehr gewinnen lassen können. Also gibt es eine Möglichkeit, dass der dich gewinnen lässt? Also dass er dann sagt, oh, jetzt hast du mich aber, puh, jetzt ist so ein trauriger Smiley, jetzt hast du mich aber erwischt,
mein Lieber. Ich hätte gerne einen Schachcomputer,
der viel besser ist als ich,
aber der mich gewinnen lässt.
Jedes Mal.
Wir haben diesen schwächeren
Schachcomputer, da können Sie verschiedene Stufen einstellen,
da können Sie gegen Magnus Carlsen spielen, aber auch wenn er neun Jahre
alt ist, wenn er achtzehn Jahre alt ist.
Hör mal zu, Sie verstehen das völlig falsch. Ich will den besten Schachcomputer, den Sie haben. All in. Aber der soll sozusagen mich gewinnen lassen. Damit andere dann so sagen, ja, damit habe ich nicht gerechnet. So was. Damit sich vor anderen besser dastehen. Hey, hey! Ich weiss, Sie ist sehr voll in diesem Schachcomputerladen. Ich lege ihn sprechen. Ich lege ihnen jetzt 150 Euro auf die Theke und dann drehe ich mich um.
Und wenn ich mich wieder umdrehe, dann will ich, dass da ein Schachcomputer liegt, denn der beste ist, den sie haben, oder der mich gewinnen lässt.
Okay, haben wir uns verstanden gerade?
Ihre Augen sehen so aus, als hätten sie drei Tage nicht geschlagen.
Ich muss gewinnen.
Versuch gegen den Schachcomputer zu spielen.
Schachcomputer sind viel besser in dem Spiel. Ich will einmal gewinnen und es ist mir mittlerweile egal, ob er mich gewinnen lässt oder nicht, okay? Ich drehe mich jetzt um. Sir, Sir, Sir. Kann ich mich umdrehen? Sir, ja, haben Sie gerade eine Rochade gemacht? Sie standen doch gerade noch vor mir. Ich habe rochiert, ich habe mein Leben rochiert.
Oh, rochiert, ja.
Spannend. Also ich finde das interessant. Und da ist auch die Frage, ab wann hat man da jetzt mal so eine Gesetzmäßigkeit entdeckt, die vor dem Schachgericht zulässig ist. Ja, es ist spannend. Ich mag solche Schachgeschichten auf jeden Fall, weil es irgendwie so diese reine Gedankenkraft ist, auch irgendwie diese legendären Schachturniere und sowas damals in den 80ern mit Kalter Krieg und sowas, das ist natürlich auch spannend. Wo man sich unterm Tisch getreten hat. Sich getreten hat. Ja, und da wurde es auch nicht zufrieden. der KGB schon die Daumenschraube angelegt hat, du, wenn du nicht gewinnst, mein Lieber, da da da! So, und dann
war es natürlich intensiv. Das KGB hat
vorgeschlagen, tritt dem einfach unter dem Tisch gegen
Schienbein. Man denkt so, das ist euer Vorschlag? Man hat gesagt, das KGB briefed mich für das Turnier. Ja, genau, ich dachte, sie haben jetzt irgendwie Schwächen in der Strategie meines Gegners gefunden. Ne, ne, treten sie einfach so ein bisschen gegen hier, sehen Sie das? Au! Ja, genau. Aua! Ja, das ist so eine Stelle, die tut ein bisschen mehr weh. Einfach so ein bisschen ab und zu mal. Wir empfehlen nach Zug drei und nach Zug siebzehn. Ja, die waren ja auch so paranoid, die dachten dann, sie werden abgehört und sowas in der Richtung. Da gab es viele Konten dann nur ganz speziell spielen. Ja genau, erst hat der eine den anderen beschuldigt, dann hat der andere den anderen wieder beschuldigt. Ich glaube, der Amerikaner hat darauf bestanden, dass sie mit seinem Star Wars Schachspiel spielen, also wo man dann nicht so die Dame hat, sondern Luke Skywalker und er hat gesagt, ich kann nur mit dem Set spielen. Wohingegen Kramnik gerne mit dem Zauberschach von Harry Potter spielen wollte. Und dann musste halt die internationale Schachgemeinschaft überlegen, kann man Schachspiel spielen, wo Star Wars gegen Harry Potter spielt? Ja, oder wäre das so Avenger Civil War Unsinn? Crossover, das keinen Sinn ergibt. Und am Ende hat man gesagt, okay, dann nehme ich die Garfield-Sachen und du die Snoopy-Sachen. Das ist nämlich ein Universum. Garfield und Snoopy sind im gleichen Universum, mal nebenbei. Das passt zumindest von der Lore her. Und dann hat man gesagt, okay, das stimmt schon. Da wurde ein ethisches Komitee ins Leben gerufen, was sich der Sache bemächtigt. Und die haben dann 50 Seiten Manifesto verfasst, in dem rauskam, dass man es lieber sein lassen sollte. Und daher kommt dann das Schachbrett, was wir heute alle kennen, das schwarz-weiße. Genau. Daher kommt das mit den einigermaßen anonymisierten Figuren. Man sieht nicht mehr so genau, dass es mal Luke Skywalker und Darth Vader war eigentlich. Was man, ich war ja in Peru und was man in Peru kaufen konnte. Echt, du warst in Peru? Ja, vor ein paar Wochen. Ach krass, erzähl mir mehr von Peru. Erzähl mir mehr von Peru.
Das Land ist so super interessant.
Da gab es nämlich Schachbretter überall zu kaufen, wo die Inka schwarz waren, also die schwarzen Figuren, und die weissen Figuren waren die Spanier.
Ach geil, das finde ich ja viel spannender, so wirklich Konflikte zu machen.
Und die Spanier waren auch fucking Briten, also die Knights waren Pferde, wo die Spanien draufsass, und bei den Inkas sind die auf Alpakas geritten. Och, ja das ist ja immer so das Ding, dass diese Meso-Völker keine Kavallerie haben. In Age of Empires haben die keine Kavallerie, keine Pferde, aber dass die auf Alpakas reiten können, da sind die Age of Empires Entwickler nicht draufgekommen. Da laufen die dann nur durch die Gegend schnell. Aber sind die schneller? Rennen nicht. Sind schneller. Der Adlerkrieger ist, ich weiß nicht, ob er schneller ist als der Speer, aber ähnlich schnell auf jeden Fall. Aber da könnt ihr gerne mich in den Kommentaren. Könnt ihr mich gerne korrigieren. Aber ja, warum nicht? Ich will jetzt am Wochenende, und das wollte ich mit dir drüber
reden, ausführlich,
weil ich das so spannend fand. Ich bin auf der Autobahn
gefahren, kleinen Mini-Kurzurlaub
im Nachbarland mit dem Auto gedüst
und da war Stau,
weil verlängert das Wochenende, alle fahren,
war Stau. Und mein
Google Maps
hat sich dann ganz tolle Tricks
sich überlegt. Und rückblickend habe ich überlegt, ob es noch einen anderen Mode gibt, weil es gibt ja schönste Route, schnellste Route, kürzeste Route. Und ich glaube, ich habe so einen Arschloch Mode, so Arschloch-Route gewählt, weil... Stammstreifen bis nach Frankreich. Ja, es war fast das, weil es war so dirty, dirty little Tricks, die in Google vorgeschlagen hat, weil ich höre, ich höre auf Google, ich vertraue Google hundertprozentig an.
Ich denke mir, Google kennt alle Staus, es kennt die genauen Wartezeiten, es kennt die Alternativrouten, weil es einfach so viele Daten hat und es kennt vor allem auch Sperrungen und sowas. Und dann hat Google gesagt, so jetzt fahr hier mal ab und ich so, okay,etwegen. Und dann fahr aber nicht ab, sondern bleib auf der Abfahrspur. Man kann nämlich ja auf manchen Abfahrspuren verschieden abfahren. Man kann aber auch dann, weil es auch wieder Auffahrten gibt, hinten wieder auf die Autobahn drauf. Alter, das schlägt dir fucking Google vor? Und ich bin abgebogen. Und es ist ja unmöglich, man bleibt ja quasi auf der Bahn. Man nutzt nur diese Abfahrspur. Und dann bin ich abgefahren und dachte mir, wo muss ich denn hier rechts abbiegen? Und Google so, ne, fahr mal weiter. Und ich so, okay, dann muss ich die nächste Ausfahrt nehmen. Und Google so, ne, fahr mal weiter. Und dann bin ich weitergefahren, um dann wieder auf die Bahn aufzufahren, wo Stau ist. Wie assi ist das denn? Und dann stand da, vier Minuten, habe ich gespart. Vier Minuten,
was ja wirklich einfach für so einen Minitrick
und dann dachte ich mir aber auch, wie genial,
warum machen das nicht eh alle, weil
ja, aber es funktioniert ja nur, weil es nicht alle
machen. Eben, aber
warum machen das nicht alle? Google ist per Definition
eigentlich unmoralisch, weil sie ausnutzt, dass
nur sie diese Tricks machen und alle anderen nicht.
Die müssen ja eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass alle so
fahren wie Google, damit es sinnvoll ist. Aber viele fragen, weil zum einen fahren nicht alle mit Google. Das lehne ich ab. Nein, ich glaube nicht. Fahren nicht die meisten Leute mit Google Maps? Nee. Dann, warum machen das nicht per se schon mal alle, weil meine statistische Erhebung ist, im Straßenverkehr fahren 80 Prozent Arschlöcher. Boah, aber da bin ich jetzt echt enttäuscht. Ich auch. Also da braucht man so eine Ethikkommission, finde ich, so bei Google, dass die sagen, nee, sowas machen wir nicht, weil, vor allem du machst ja auch anderen Leuten vor, wie man Arschloch ist, sondern, nee, du musst so fahren, dass wir alle so fahren würden, dass es dann auch funktionieren würde. Nee, das gefällt mir gar nicht. Da schreibe ich mal einen gepfefferten Brief an Google in die Google-Suchleiste, schreibe ich rein, jetzt passt mal auf, ihr Schweine. Ich weiß, dass ihr mich hier seht. Genau, ich spreche in die Webcam. Ich weiß, dass ihr gerade zuschaut, ihr Schweine, okay? Ich weiß, dass ihr da drin seid, ich weiß, dass ihr da irgendwo auf der anderen Seite seid. Hört mal auf mit dem Quatsch, okay? Das geht echt nicht gut. Was ein Scheiß. Was ein Scheiß, es ist wirklich asozial. Ich finde es so asozial.
Eine Sache, die ich mir denke, beim Autofahren ist, wir haben in der Automobiltechnologie solche Fortschritte gemacht. Der Airbag, der Drei-Punkte-Gurt, der Zigarettenanzünder, der immer noch serienmässig drin ist, weil man liebt es doch im Auto zu rauchen. Die Sicherheitssachen mit Airbags. Ich muss rauchen. Der Hybridantrieb. Und ich stecke mir gleich zwei an. Oder eine dicke, so eine dicke Zigarette, keine Zigarre, sondern eine dicke, so eine Jumbo-Zigarette. Mit einem Dingfilter, daumendicke Zigarette. Es ist so eine spezielle Lösung, dieses, ich werde ganz heiß, dass ich quasi Feuer bin, aber Feuer ist so ein weirdes New Pole, aber ich bin kein Feuer. Das ist so eine weirde Lösung für ein Problem, was eigentlich gar nicht so doll existiert. Es ist so verrückt, du hast so ein bewegendes Stahlding und darin hast du so ein Fingerhut Magma einfach, so ein Fingerhut Magma ist da drin, einfach so fucking heiß, wie es nur sein kann. Damit zünde ich dir das an. Das Ding sofort brennen, wenn du es auch nur berührst. Wenn du auch noch auf die Idee kommst, das zu berühren. Also wir haben technische Fortgeschritte gemacht in allen Bereichen der Automobilität, nur nicht im Bereich der Kommunikation mit anderen Autofahrern. Wir haben seit Hunderten von Jahren zwei Möglichkeiten zu kommunizieren, A Hupe, B Lichthupe. Hallo, ihr spricht UN333X, nee. Ja, ich stehe da zwei Autos vor Ihnen gerade im Stau. Genau, hier, ich bin der weisse Ford Focus. Erwische ich Sie da hinten im Corsa? Ja, ich bin der Peugeot, ja. Sie sind der Peugeot Corsa? Ich bin der Peugeot. Okay, Ihr Licht hinten rechts ist defekt. Oh, das ist nett, danke schön. Können wir auf meiner Frequenz runtergehen hier? Ich bin der grosse Daxer LKW. Sie müssen raus. Hallo, Sie müssen komplett raus. Wie bitte? Sie haben mich gar nicht angefunkt. Ihr seid alle in meiner Frequenz drin. Man kann immer aufhören, da ist händig eine Ausfahrtstreifen und ein langzufahrige Schweine. Ich stehe hier schon seit Bottrop. So, wenn eine grosse BMW da vorne nicht mehr ernstlich raus drüber fährt. Sag mal, ich komme gleich rüber und schlapp da noch ein Schwochenbeut. Es gibt keine Möglichkeiten. Naja, vielleicht aus gutem Grund Möglichkeit, also dass in den hunderten von Jahren nicht einfach mal, also meine ganz kurze grobe Idee, hinzugefügt zu Hupe und Lichthupe, einfach so eine Klappe, die außen aufgeht beim Auto, so wie so eine Art kleines Verkehrsschild, das aufgeht vom Auto, wo draufsteht, fick dich. Einfach straight einfach und du fährst an jemandem vorbei und machst die Klappe auf und dann machst du die Klappe wieder zu. Wie beim Badmobil, wo du einen so einen Knopf hast. Einfach so Kommunikation. Warum geht es nicht weiter? Ich denke es noch weiter, ich denke es noch weiter. Und zwar habe ich, das sind wie diese Magnettafeln, die man als Kind hatte. Und zwar hast du so einen kleinen Stift und dann kannst du links quasi an deine Tür was reinschreiben. Aber dann ist ja das offene Auto, ne? Ne, ne, wenn es zu ist, geht es zu, schreibst du was rein und dann kannst du es wie so ein Handkurbeler, kannst es so rauskurbeln, was ausklappen. Das ist super. Und jetzt wird es genial, wenn du es nämlich wieder reinschiebt, geht es an so einen Magnetstreifen, wobei dann löscht es sich wieder. Dann kannst du eine neue Botschaft reinschreiben direkt, spart Zeit, spart Zeit! Perfekt, warum gibt's so was nicht? Ständig bin ich bei den Autos, wo ich nicht sagen will, vor allem, ich weiss ja, denkt mir ja selber auch oft beim Autofahren, mach ich was falsch, bin ich das Arschloch, habe ich jemanden geschnitten, wie funktioniert das hier, würde mir jemand einfach mal irgendwie so Beleidigungen an so einer Tafel präsentieren, wüsste ich einfach mehr, was los ist. Warum gibt man nicht mehr Kommunikation? Ich meine, die Schifffahrt hat seit Jahrhunderten dieses Flaggensystem, wo die einfach sagen können, du dummes Arschloch, ihr habt mich geschnitten. Und Funk. Du sagst immer, du musst dreimal deinen Namen sagen, deines Schiffes. Maritima, Maritima, Maritima, Calling, ich habe den Funkschein noch nicht gemacht. Aber kann man auch ablehnen oder muss man dann mit denen? Nee, nee, du kannst wegdrücken. Aber das ist doch so gut, also die Kommunikation, man hat keine Chance. Auf der anderen Seite habe ich mir auch gedacht, welches fucking Genie hat die Lichthupe erfunden? Ja, aber da muss ich gerade sagen, ich würde nämlich vor allem zustimmen, dass man sich nicht entschuldigen kann. Weil ich bin jetzt bei der Autofahrt, wollte ich mit dem Scheibenwischer betätigen, bin dabei an die Lichthub gekommen. So, und dann bin ich dem Typen eh schon tausend Kilometer gefolgt und immer so dicht in einer Stuhlstange geklebt. Plötzlich hupe ich den weg, war nicht meine Intention. Sorry, sorry, großes Sorry. Habe ich die Lichthupe schnell ausgemacht. Ich habe schon gesehen, Arme flogen in die Luft vor mir in dem kleinen Autochin. Arme flogen in die Luft, aufgeregt wurde sie sich über mich. Mittelfinger wurden überlegt zu zeigen. Ich hingegen, dann sitze ich da hinten in meinem Auto und wusste nicht, wie soll ich mich jetzt entschuldigen. Nein, nein, aber große Handbewegungen können missverstanden werden. Es gibt keine Entschuldigunggeste, es gibt natürlich die gefalteten Hände, dieHände. Aber dann muss man seinen Klenker loslassen, das geht nicht. Vor allem, oft ist es so bei mir so, jemand fährt hinter mir mit Abblendlicht an, ballert mir einfach schön rein. Warum kann man nicht nach hinten Licht hupen? Das wäre oft viel sinnvoller, einfach mit den Rücklichtern zu Licht hupen und zu sagen so, hör auf, hör auf, hör auf, hör auf, hör auf. Das ist wie so den Müll abwerfen, um den Gegner zu verwirren.
Ja, genau.
So noch ganz schnelles Licht an.
Aber ich meine jetzt mal wirklich, irgendwann wurde ja ein Auto entwickelt, das ein Abblendlicht hatte,
dass man das Licht auf zwei Stufen stellen konnte.
Wahrscheinlich hat damals noch niemand an Lichthupe gedacht,
bis irgendwann irgendjemand oder eine Gruppe von Menschen angefangen hat,
dieses System, Abblendlicht, als Lichthupe zu benutzen, also das so flackernd hin und her zu machen. Und das wurde so normal, dass das ja heute in der Fahrschule gelehrt wird als Technik. Lass uns ganz genau bleiben. Abblendlicht, damit meinen wir das ganz normale Standard. Ich fahre bei Dunkelheit Licht. Genau, das ist das hochgestellte Licht. Ist das ganz normale Licht. Lichthub doch. Das nennt man Abblendlicht. Nee, Abblendlicht ist das, das blendet. Nein, das ist die Lichthupe. Das Abblendlicht blendet nicht. Lass da ganz genau bleiben. Wir beide einfach direkt anfangen zu tippen. Abblendlicht, Scheinwerferlicht, das so eingestellt ist, dass ein entgegenkommendes Fahrzeug nicht geblendet wird. Ach, dann gibt es, tagfahrlicht ja das ist so wie so das ist das was ich beim kategorien mal an habe und denkt dann ich habe licht an du hast völlig recht es ergibt ja auch von der wortbedeutung viel mehr sinn dass man abblendet man blendet nach unten sozusagen so du hast recht es gibt also abblendlicht und fernlicht dann habe ich es falsch gesagt hast recht das heißt du aktivierst das flicht ein paar Mal, das ist die Lichthube. Genau. Und das ist ja so gängig geworden, dass das in der Fahrschule mit aufgenommen wurde. Aber das ist ja wahrscheinlich kein Konstruktionsfeature, sondern ein Userfeature, was die Leute irgendwie angefangen haben, so zu benutzen. Es muss ja irgendwo Pioniere gegeben haben, die dieses Fernlicht so eingesetzt haben. Der neue Saab, das Arschlochauto mit der einzigartigen Funktion des Blendens. Jetzt können Sie die anderen Fahrzeugteilnehmer blenden, wenn Sie ihnen sagen wollen, dass Sie mit ihrem Fahrstil unzufrieden sind. Weg, weg von der Bahn, weg von der Bahn! Unser neuer Saab mit einer Höchstgeschwindigkeit von 21 kmh und einer Pferdestärke von 9 hat jetzt die Möglichkeit, die schwächeren Verkehrsmitglieder wegzublenden. Wegzublenden, Saab, Saab, Fahr, fahren wie ein Arschloch. Fahr mit Saab. Weniger Konkurrenz, weniger gute Sprüche, muss man auch sagen.
Ich bin ja passender Sprecher, auch zwei, die sich nie entscheiden können.
Aber ich finde es spannend, weil es muss irgendeinen ersten Pionier gegeben haben, der das eingesetzt hat.
Ja, ich bin ja immer noch für sprechende Autos.
Warum ist die Hupe, ist die, das finde ich wie, alle Hupen klingen ja anders, ne?
Alle Hupen klingen ein bisschen anders. Böööö natürlich interessant, warum muss es denn überhaupt so ein Ton sein? Kann es
nicht auch ein Sorry, sorry, ja, dass man verschiedene Hupen hat, das stimmt schon, ja,
genau, weg, scusi, scusi, scusi, mea culpa, mea, aber es ist auch die Frage, wenn man lange
drauf drückt oder wenn man einen Unfall hat, dann kann es natürlich auch sein, dass man dann so Weg! Scusi! Scusi, scusi! Mea culpa! Mea!
Aber ist halt die Frage, wenn man lange drauf drückt oder wenn man einen Unfall hat, dann kann es natürlich auch sein, dass man dann so, wenn man auch die Sorry-Hupe, wenn die noch im Sorry-Mode ist und du hast einen schweren Unfall und dein Kopf knallt gegen die Hupe ist einfach Soooooooori! Stimmt, du musst eigentlich irgendwas machen, was man auch lang sagen kann.
Asche auf mein Haupt ist natürlich dann so, du hast so ein, ah, sch, du hast halt so einen MP3-Soundfeil, aber es stimmt, warum gibt es nicht mehr Kommunikation, ich würde mir das wünschen, ich würde mir das wünschen, warum gibt es das nicht, die Polizei hat ja so Anzeigetafeln, so bitte folgen oder sie sind verhaftet, lauf du Schwein oder so, solche Sachen, wir kriegen dich, sowas in der Richtung wird dann da angezeigt.
Wir haben eine heisse Spur, das hat mal ein Kumpel erzählt.
Wo waren sie um 11 Uhr Mittwoch auf der Autobahn? Warum ist sowas nicht serienmässig bei allen Autos dabei, wo der Beifahrer einfach mal über eine App schön tippen kann, was in diesen Textzeilen angezeigt wird? Das ist doch fantastisch. Das hat mal ein Kumpel erzählt, der war mal mit Leuten, so Jungs im jugendlichen Alter, im Urlaub und wurde auch viel gekifft im Auto, war er nicht, aber wurden die angehalten und dann wollte der besonders lustig sein und hat gesagt, na, haben Sie schon eine heiße Spur, Officer? Und ich finde das so eine selbstbewusste erste Line, haben sie schon eine heisse Spur, weil es ja den Polizistenjob allein auf dieses Detektive, Rumdetektiven klein macht. Fand ich aber nicht so schlecht. Na haben Sie schon eine heiße Spur. Und dann wurde ich angehalten, weil ich auf dem Roller gefahren bin, spätabends und sollte pusten. In das Röhrchen pusten, Alkoholtest, wurde ich rausgezogen, weil ich so Schlangenlinien gefahren bin, weil ich so Spaß gemacht habe. Weil du wieder Formel 1 gespielt hast. Wollte ich auch sagen. Ich habe gespielt, die Striche sind Lava und deswegen muss ich um die Striche herumfahren. Okay, bei 160. Genau. Und dann musste ich pusten und wollte ich auch erst sagen, na haben Sie schon eine heiße Spur. Aber ich finde das eigentlich einen guten Satz. Nein, nein, respektiv doch bitte lieber. Macht keine Sp... Keine Späße. Macht keine Späße. Aber einen Flickflack vielleicht. Macht einen kleinen Flickflack, wenn ihr gewonnen habt. Na ja, da hat man Google Maps halt gesagt, sei das verdammte Arschloch, was ich dir anzeige. Und dann bin ich draufgefahren und dachte mir, weil ich bin dann so viel Autos vorbeigefahren. Und das Geile an diesem Trick ist ja, an diesem furchtbaren Arschloch-Trick ist ja, dass niemand merkt, dass du bescheisst. Ja, das ist das Schlimmste, ja. Weil wenn du auf dem Standstreifen vorbeifährst an allen und dann wieder links fährst, wissen alle holy shit, was ein Arschloch. Aber bei diesem denken einfach, du bist ein Auffahrer und lassen dich brav wieder rein. No Backlashes. Boah, das ist das perfekte Verbrechen. Es ist das perfekte Verbrechen. Ey Mann, ich habe Angst, dass das jetzt alle machen, weil das echt scheiße macht sowas nicht. Wenn ich jemanden sehe, der da aufhört mit einem Podcast-Ufo-Sticker am Heck, dann gibt es aber eine schöne Lichtruppe in euer Gesicht rein, Freunde. Direkt neben dem Sylt-Sticker. Ist aber eigentlich ein guter Sketch. Auch so Arschloch-Google finde ich auch nicht schlecht. Also nehmen Sie jetzt die Rettungsgasse und fahren Sie bis zum Anfang des Staus, einfach so, oder fahren Sie jetzt über den Seitenstreifen bis kurz vor Bochum. Jetzt stellen Sie sich mal nicht so an, wir wollen doch alle ans Ziel. Jetzt nehmen Sie Ihr gefaktes Blaulicht aus dem Handschuhfach, setzen es auf und fahren an allen Autos vorbei. Es ist, das haben wir Ihnen vorher bei Amazon bestellt. Aber auch wenn man dann so googelt, Paragraph 19, Kleinunternehmer oder sowas, brauche ich das wirklich oder sowas? Und dann so, nein, da machen wir uns nichts vor. Da guckt doch je niemand genau hin. Wo kein Kläger, da kann man nicht. Ja, okay. Das ist schwierig, aber könnte man gut machen eigentlich. Ich hoffe, dass sich das nicht durchsetzt, sondern es braucht ethische Leitlinien für Verkehr, Hilfsmittel.
Also willst du gerade sagen, dass Google ethische Leitlinien braucht?
Ja, das ist ja. Wow.
Nee, sag ich jetzt mal.
Aber da hast du dich mal auf ein Fenster gelegt und sagst, Google braucht ein bisschen moralische Anleitung?
Ich hau da jetzt mal was raus.
Okay, hab ich so noch nie gehört.
Ist nicht der Slogan von Google, don't be evil, was einfach schon mal genial ist? Er ist, glaube ich, neu, er ist noch besser geworden. Try not to be evil. Try not to be evil all the time. Be evil if it's necessary. Be evil if it makes money. But if it doesn't make money, you don't really need to be evil all the time. Das ist unser neuer Slogan. Aber lustig, dass ausgerechnet Google die einzigen mit dem Claim, don't really need to be evil all the time. Das ist unser Neujahr-Slogan.
Aber lustig, dass ausgerechnet Google die einzigen mit dem Claim don't be evil, somit das the most evil thing geworden sind. Ja, aber das ist doch klar. Wenn ich einen Bösewicht-Firma in meinem Science-Fiction-Roman schreiben würde, würde ich auch sagen, deren Claim ist we are not evil. We are not evil. Don't even think about it. So krass. Die haben uns so sehr verarscht, dass die Firma, die sagt, don't be evil, am Ende das Böseste ist, hätte man ja so auch nicht angenommen. Naja, und dann jedenfalls fuhr ich weiter. Ich google mal ganz kurz, ist Google böse? Und schau mal, was Google mir sagt. Google ist nicht böse, ist das erste Ergebnis, wenn man ist Google böse googelt.
Okay, gut, dann haben wir das also geklärt. Google ist nicht mehr nicht böse, habe ich, aber jetzt wird es langsam, das müssen wir an seinen Anwalt dazuholen.
Don't be evil, direkt übersetzt sei nicht böse, war jahrelang das inoffizielle Motto von Google, die Zeiten sind jetzt offenbar vorbei, die haben es abgelegt.
Was ist denn der neue Slogan? Haben die nicht, ne? Google ist über Slogan hinaus. Wir kennen dich besser als du selbst, sowas? Ich bin dann noch weitergefahren und dann sollte ich wieder abfahren und dann bin ich auch abgefahren, das war einfach eine normale Ausfahrt, um dann an der Ampel einen U-Turn zu machen, der da verboten war, durchgezogene Linie, U-Turn gemacht, habe ich dann einfach gemacht, weil Google sagt mir das, um wieder auf die Bahn aufzufahren. Das gleiche gemacht, nur noch dreckiger. Da bin ich wirklich auf eine Ausfahrt gefahren, um in einer Ampel rum mit dem U-Turn und dann wieder auf die Bahn aufgefahren. Das heißt, das war nicht mal mehr so, aber jetzt,, dann wurde es langsam Richtung wirklich benutzt, den Standstreifen mässig. Ich habe leider die Stimme aus. An der Stimme hätte ich noch Nuancen erkennen können. Hey, Stefan, du willst also früher ankommen. Da hätte ich ein paar Ideen für dich. Ich habe drei Umschläge für dich. Das erste ist, wir machen es auf die herkömmliche Weise, okay? Damit bist du schon 19 mal in den Ziel gekommen, 19 mal okay pünktlich. Hast du Zeit gespart? Ich glaube nicht. Umschlag Nummer zwei ist das, du lässt Luigi machen. Du lässt mal kurz das Lenkrad los, okay? Und wir machen das für dich. Weil Mündigkeit drei ist, du bist in zwei Minuten da, darfst aber keine Fragen stellen, was passiert ist.
Ach, ist auch nicht schlecht. Naja, und so bin ich dann irgendwie viel zu früh auf die Zukunft. Du hast dich schlecht gefühlt, oder? Das ist jetzt wieder so, dürftest du dich vor Gericht auf Google berufen. So dieses klassische, ich habe nur Befehle ausgeführt Argument, wenn jetzt jemand sagt, ja, das war aber echt gemein von dir. ich muss nur, ich höre, ich bin abgefahren. Oder hast du die ethische Pflicht, solche Anweisungen abzulehnen, wenn Google dir sowas vorschlägt? Also beim zweiten Mal habe ich aus purem, ja, Hass und Malice gehandelt. Beim ersten Mal nicht, beim ersten Mal wusste ich ja nicht, ich dachte, wir fahren einfach ab, um dann irgendwo auf eine andere Bahn zu fahren, wo kein Stau ist. Und dann hat Google gesagt, nee, wir wollen nicht. Ich finde, Google sollte immer, wenn du dir so eine Abbiegung zeigst, sollte dir so ein Icon anzeigen, so zwischen Mutter Teresa und Hitler, so einfach so verschiedene, wir sind jetzt gerade so bei Genghis Khan Niveau, damit du weisst, ah, das ist jetzt schon ein bisschen, das ist merkwürdig, ein bisschen link, aber ich mach's trotzdem noch. Genghis Khan gehe ich mit, Hitler bin ich dann nicht mehr dabei. Oder so eine Red Dead Redemption mässig, wo man sich entscheiden kann, bin ich ein guter Cowboy, der das Gesetz ehrt? Genau, welche Entscheidung triffst du? Oder bin ich ein schlechter Cowboy, dann hast du aber auch ein gewisses Kopfgeld auf dir ausgesetzt und dann musst du irgendwo immer dich freikaufen. Und da hätte ich gern so eine, zwischen Rot und Blau, so eine Liste. Das konntest du auch bei The Old Republic, bei dem Star Wars MMORPG machen, dass du dann entscheiden konntest, jetzt wirst du noch ein Sith. Ja, und je nachdem, wie du dich entscheidest, kriegst du ein anderes Ende. Genau. Dass du dann einen anderen Abspann siehst und ein anderes da ankommst. Ja gut, das andere Ende hatte ich, war viel zu früh da und dann musste ich warten vor der Tür. Von daher, das andere Ende hatte ich. Aber es war schon spannend und beim zweiten Mal, ja, muss ich mir das ankreiden, das darf ich nicht machen. Da wusste ich ja, dass ich Google auf Arschloch gestellt habe. Ja, es ist eine wilde Welt. Ich fahre auch immer falsch, ich kann das gar nicht mit diesem Ding. Und es ist immer so peinlich, dieses Mann fährt falsch ab. und dann noch diese quälenden Sekunden, wo Google noch denkt, ah, du fährst auf der richtigen Spur und du weißt schon, nein, ich habe dich enttäuscht. Ich habe dich enttäuscht. Und es ist nur so diese quellenden Sekunden, bis Google merkt, ach nee, ich habe ihm zu viel zugetraut. Ich war zu Er ist gutmütig. Er ist tatsächlich völlig falsch gefahren. Jetzt merke ich es auch. Das ist der schlimmste Teil des Ganzen.
So diese, dieses, aber es gibt auch diese kurzen, nee, es schaltet ja nicht sofort um, sondern es gibt ja diesen kurzen Moment, wo oben steht, bitte warten, dieses, was machen wir denn jetzt?
Ja, genau.
Was machen wir denn jetzt?
Er fährt doch, er fährt doch, er fährt doch nicht einfach hier, ach, er ist abgefahren. Ja, so wenn ein Brief von der Schule kommt und deine Mutter so, ah, wow, hast du eine besondere Belohnung bekommen oder so, bist du zum Klassensprecher gewählt worden. Wow, toll. Und du weißt schon, nein, gleich kommt die Realisierung. Das ist die vier Minus in Physik. Gleich kommt die Enttäuschung. Das ist der Verweis, weil ich versucht habe, aus dem Physikraum auszubrechen. Weil Google das dir gesagt hat. Ja, Du sollst weniger mit diesem Google rumhängen, habe ich dir gesagt. Das ist ein schlechter Einfluss auf dich. Ich meine, du hast recht, das ist der schnellste Weg. Du müsstest sonst zum Hauptausgang und wieder raus. Aus dem Physikraum zu springen, ist der schnellste Weg zu uns nach Hause. Ja, stimmt. Das stimmt. Ich fand es gruselig. Und hey, bei der Physik-Schulaufgabe. Ich vibriere einfach so oft, wie die Antwort richtig ist. Ich geb einfach, wie viel Mol, vibriere ich einfach 16.000 Mal und schreibst du deine 16.000 hin. Hat bei niemandem auch funktioniert. Mit so einem Don't the Evil Shirt und einem Google-Schrift. Gibt's da Shirts davon? Das ist ja perfekt. Ich will unbedingt so ein Shirt haben, so ein Don't be evil-Shirt. Aber auch an andere Gerichte. Don't be evil to me. Geh mit mir lieb. Don't be mean to me. I'm sensitive. Ja, das war auf jeden Fall ein einschneidendes Erlebnis und ja, irre, dass das geht.
Du hast dir einfach so einen schönen Konzerlaub gegönnt, oder was? Einfach nochmal schön an die Riviera.
Kurz, kurz, kurzlaub.
Ich habe den Rückentag nicht mitbekommen, ich stand wie bei jedem Feiertag immer vor verschlossenen Supermarkttüren, das ist für mich das Feiertagsfeeling Einfach so, da haben vor hunderten Jahren Leute sich aufgeopfert,
damit es uns heute besser geht und ich denke mir,
fuck ey, warum kann ich nicht einkaufen?
Wo kriege ich jetzt meinen Dr. Pepper her?
Und stehe ich da und dann musst du wieder
so den Alternativplan machen.
Dann musst du wieder beim Bahnhof irgendwie gucken,
dass du dir was aus dem Automaten rausholst oder so.
Es gibt jetzt Dr. Pepper Vanille.
Vanille Float.
Das ist sogar nicht nur Dr. Pepper Vanille, sondern Vanille Eis. Ein Float ist ja wahrscheinlich für uns europäische Mägen eher ungewöhnlich. Ein Softdrink, Cola Fanta, mit einer Kugel Eis drin. Aber Moment, aber in dem Drink, den man kauft, der Softdrink, da ist keine Kugel Eis drin, sondern es ist einfach nur Vanille Flavor drin. Ich glaube, es ist einfach nur ein Produkt. Kann man sich das sparen. Ja, ich wollte es einfach nur sagen, damit die Leute jetzt nicht verwirrt sind beim Rekal. Ja, aber ich finde, es ist ein anderes Gefühl. Ich finde, es ist ein nur ein Produkt. Ja, aber ich wollte es einfach nur sagen, damit die Leute jetzt nicht verwirrt sind bei Amerika.
Ja, aber ich finde, es ist ein anderes Gefühl.
Ich finde, es ist ein amerikanischeres Gefühl, wenn ich es trinke.
Ein amerikanischer Name.
Ja, nee, aber es ist was anderes als Vodilla Coke.
Vodilla Float erinnere ich mich zurück, erinnert an unseren New York Urlaub.
Das macht so keinen Sinn.
Also mir schmeckt es besser.
Das gehört auch dazu.
Es ist Teil des Geschmackserlebens, es ist alles dabei.
Mich beruhigt das sehr, weil Dr. Pepper ist ja diese ominöse, niemand weiß genau, wo nachher es schmeckt und was da drin ist. Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, Tillmanns Toasties sind keine Schnitzel. Das sind die wichtigen Regeln. Das Bildungssystem funktioniert schon, muss man sagen. Allein, dass wir das wissen, es klappt schon. Das Marketing-System funktioniert. Ja, es funktioniert gut, ja. Aber und, weil ich bin irgendwie beruhigt gewesen, da habe ich dieses Vanille gesehen und dachte mir, wenn ich das jetzt trinke, weise ich eine Zutat schon mal. Ja. Es gibt einem so einen Hint. Genau. Einen kleinen Hinweis. Ja. Der Rest bleibt immer noch. Immer noch keine Ahnung. Keine Ahnung. Aber es ist für mich einfacher. Ich wusste damals auch nicht genau, wie man diesen Float trinken soll, ehrlich gesagt. Also wartet man, bis das Eis geschmolzen ist oder du hast dann auch einen Strohhalm. Und dann kann man ja nicht so schlecht durchs Eis durchstechen, trinkt man erstmal die Flüssigkeit weg. Ich weiß nicht genau, aber an sich ist das schon lecker, das kann man schon machen. Das ist schon eine feine Sache, aber hat sich nicht durchgesetzt in diesen Gefilden hier. Weiß ich noch, haben wir in der New Jersey Mall mal getrunken. Genau, ja. Und ja, ich kann mich an nichts mehr erinnern danach, der Zuckerschock war zu groß. Ich war den Rest des Tages blind, aber ich wurde netterweise an der Hand geführt. Woran ich mich noch erinnere, ist das große Flackern in meinen Augen, in der Peripherie. Das war aber konstant über den ganzen Urlaub einfach, weil wir so viel Zucker und Kalorien gegessen haben und einfach Würstchen mit Sirup gegessen haben. Das war einfach, da gab es keinen Kopf mehr. War jemand schon mal richtig nüchtern in New York? Vielleicht ist es einfach eine scheiß Stadt. Wir sehen nur alle so unsere Zuckerschock-Euforie. Die Stadt, die niemals schläft. Ja, deswegen seid ihr alle völlig im Delirium, weil niemand eine Ruhe kriegt und den ganzen Tag Zucker isst. Die Stadt, die mal dringend schlaft und sich mal hinlegen sollte. Hau dich mal aufs Ohr, New York, und iss mal einen Apfel. Das ist unsere nächste New York-Tour, ist hau dich mal aufs Ohr. Dann ist gut. Hau dich mal aufs Ohr und iss mal einen Big Apple und dann guck noch mal an. Ja. So, und dann, glaube ich, kann man anfangen. Dann sieht man, ach Gott, hier dampft es überall aus den Schächten, hier sind überall Ratten, nichts funktioniert. Hier sind menschengroße Schildkröten, was ist das, was soll das hier, Batman? Hier ist alles, wir müssen nochmal neu anfangen. Aber vielleicht macht es den Werk auch kaputt, vielleicht ist auch was Schlechtes im Maßen gar nicht schlecht. Stark, weiter, weiter, weiter. Ja, vielleicht geht es ja auch unter und wir bewundern das in zehn Jahren so wie so ein Atlantis oder sowas, dass wir dann da nochmal rumtauchen können oder sowas in der Richtung. Glaubst du, Atlantis wird noch gefunden? Das ist die einzige Stadt, auf die wir vorbereitet sind, dass die untergeht, oder nicht? Wir haben die so oft zerstört gesehen in Filmen, sei es Independence Day, sei es 2012, sei es The Day After Tomorrow, sei es Godzilla, sei es alle Badmans, 9-11, bester Film, King Kong. Wir haben New York schon so oft kaputt gesehen. These, wenn eine Atombombe auf New York fällt, ist dies nicht so krass für uns im Bewusstsein. Natürlich ist es furchtbar, da machen wir keinen Scherz jetzt. Aber der Gag, auf den ich hinaus will, der muss jetzt ganz genau platziert sein, ist nämlich der, dass wir das nicht so schlimm empfinden in unseren popkulturellen Köpfchen, wie zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, Berlin habe ich noch nicht so oft zerstört. Genau, wenn ein Komet auf die Erde fallen würde und der schlägt in New York ein, sagt man, ja, er gibt total Sinn. Wohingegen, der Komet steuert auf Seattle zu. Oh mein Gott. Wie soll das denn kaputt aussehen? Welches Gebäude stürzt da cool ein? Stösst die Space Needle, geht die dann kaputt oder spiess der sich auf? Wie so ein Schaschlingsspiess, so ein Party-Spieess, so ein Meatball. Also unsere Verteidigung sieht so aus, dass wir die Space Needle versuchen so zu neigen, dass wir den Kometen einfach direkt aufspiessen. Das ist unsere Idee.
Ja, eine Frage. Bitte, ja, da in der ersten Reihe, die Augsburger allgemein. Klaus Behrensen von der Augsburger allgemein. Sind wir uns denn sicher, dass die Space Needle so dicht ist, dass sie den Kometen aufspiesst, oder kann man sich eher vorstellen, dass es kaputt geht, wie man es annehmen würde? Naja, wir wissen nicht, aus welchem Material der Komet ist. Denken Sie an den beliebten Party-Snack, das Zahnstäbchen, wie sagt man, I don't know, ne, warte mal, I don't know what the word, toothpick. Ja, genau, aber auf Englisch weiß ich es auch, Zahnstocher, Zahnstocher auf das Käse trifft. Es ist natürlich auch die Geschwindigkeit, spielt eine Rolle. Also ob jetzt die Nadel mit hoher Geschwindigkeit auf den Kometen stösst oder die Komet mit hoher Geschwindigkeit. Letzten Endes ist es eine Sache der Wahrscheinlichkeit. Wenn wir die Nadel richtig ausrichten, kann es sein, dass es klappt, aber es kann auch gut sein, dass es nicht funktioniert. Ich hätte die Übersetzung nicht mehr mitbekommen am Ende, aber vielen Dank. Aber es ist eine interessante Idee, man könnte es mal probieren. Das ist ein großes Trampolin. Wann kommt der Komet, wann kommt der Asteroid, wann passiert da mal was? Ja, vor literally drei Tagen. Wie? Wo denn? Ja, haben wir doch einen Kometen abgeballert. Die NASA hat einen Kometen abgeballert. Echt? Das ist nicht mitbekommen. What? Wie kann ich das denn nicht mitbekommen? Doch. Ich war so tief in dem Schachdrama drin, dass ich das gar nicht... Ja, das ist auch meine Warnung. Das war auch meine Warnung an euch. Das Schachdrama ist spannend und cool und hey. Und endlich haben wir Statistiker mal wieder was zu tun. Aber schaut bitte weiterhin in den Himmel, Leute. Das ist wichtig. Aber schaut nach oben. Look up! Look it up! Wir haben einen ganzen Film gedreht, verdammt nochmal! Ja, und zwar war das die sogenannte Dart-Mission. Es klingt wie Stoff aus Hollywood. Der Kurs eines Asteroiden muss verändert werden, mit Hilfe Sonde so groß wie ein Getränkeautomat bei der NASA-Rechtel-Mission Dart.
In der Nacht endete das Manöver mit einem krachenden Erfolg.
Ein krachender Erfolg. Ist das eine gute Umschreibung für ein Himmelsgestein, das auf die Erde zufliegt?
Die Mission endete mit einem krachenden Erfolg.
Oh, okay.
So gross wie ein Getränkeautomat.
Und man sieht es immer grösser.
Ja, aber das ist Getränkeautomat finde ich noch besser.
Ja, aber sag doch Kühlschrank.
Oder also sag doch nicht Getränkeautomat.
Das ist ja wirklich albern.
Noch komplizierter, macht es noch komplizierter.
Aber der wäre... So ein Viertel-Container, kann man sagen. Ja, so zwei Tischtennisplatten, so ungefähr. So eine halbe Tischtennisplatte, ungefähr. Ja, hui. Immer einmal ich, einmal du. Ja, einmal jeder Podcaster, einmal pro Folge. Und dann hat man nämlich gesehen, aber das ist auch ... Du kannst dich nicht als großen Space-Fan hier hinstellen. Nee, ich ... Komplett ignorieren, du Arsch, du scheiß Arschloch. Jedenfalls wird dieser Asteroid immer grösser, immer grösser, man sieht immer mehr Steine und dann hört das Bild auf. Und dann sind die ausgebrochenen Jubel. Da habe ich mir gedacht, hm, ich habe jetzt keine Explosion gesehen. Aber hätte der denn Schaden angerechnet, wenn der in den Kühlschrank grösser auf die Erde niedergerast wäre? Ne, Moment. Nee, Moment. Der Kühlschrank war die Sonde. Ach so! Und wie gross war der eigentliche das Himmelsgestein? Asteroidkomet, ich will mich jetzt nicht wieder der Kritik aussetzen. Deswegen sag ich mal Space-Klumpen, Spaceball. Die Spannung steigt. Wie gross war der Spaceball? Nach dem ersten Jubilies die Wissenschaftliche Koordinatorin der Dartmission Nancy Chabot, ihrer Begeisterung freien Lauf, das wollen glaube ich diese Bilder immer näher und näher, wir haben jahrelang für diesen Moment gearbeitet, seit 2015, ist noch nicht so lang. Wir haben immer wieder darüber gesprochen, so wird es werden, wir werden spektakuläre Bilder sehen, jetzt wurden meine Warten noch übertroffen. Und wie groß ist es? Fussballstadion. Getränkeautomat trifft Fussballstadion. Wow, okay. Jetzt ergibt es Sinn, weil es gibt Getränkeautomaten in Fussballstadien. Weniger Kühlschränke. Sagen wir so ein Counter, wo man das kauft. Ja, ja, genau. Davon so ein Achtel. Oh, okay. 19 Fussbälle, stell dir so ein Sack Fussbälle vor. Ein Sack Fussball trifft auf Fussballstadion. Aber der kam ja von außen, ne? Oder kam der von innen? Der Asteroid? Wenn wir uns jetzt mal vorstellen, die Sonne ist der Mittelpunkt des Sonnensystems, unseres Sonnensystems. Gott sei Dank. Und wenn jetzt aber der Asteroid von außen kommt, dann würde uns der doch näher an die Sonne drücken ein bisschen, oder, wenn der einschlägt. Ist das nicht sogar gut? Nee, das ist schlecht, weil wir wollen ja kälter werden. Wir wollen kälter werden. Wäre es nicht schlau, dass wir nur Kometen durchlassen, die uns weiter von der Sonne wegschieben? Ja, oder halt so einen kleinen Propeller an die Erde bauen, der uns so ein bisschen nach außen drückt.
Oder ist die Erde so elastisch, dass die den Schlag sozusagen auffängt,
wie so ein Gummiball, wie so
ein Stressball, aber gar nicht ein bisschen
Energie, glaube ich, geht immer noch nach draußen,
oder? Ist das nicht eine Idee? Es kommt tatsächlich auf die
Grösse an. Ich glaube, ein Fussballstadion reicht da nicht aus.
Ein bisschen? Nein, ich glaube, da brauche ich nur ein
grösserer, da brauchen wir drei Fussballstadien. Du hältst immer
noch am Propeller fest. Ich glaube, bin immer noch der Meinung, das ist die beste, weil er kühlt auch in unsere Richtung und nach außen schiebt er uns ein bisschen weg. Wir sollten einen grossen Propeller bauen. Gut, finde ich eine gute Idee. Du kannst ja schon mal, wenn du jetzt anfängst in fünf Jahren oder sieben Jahren, wie es jetzt in dem Fall der Fall war, Wahnsinn, dass man sowas so lange vorhersehen kann, ne? Dass sie 2015 schon auf dem Schirm hatten, dass sieben Jahre später die diesen Kometen abwehren wollen. Unfassbar, oderageddon. Okay. Das war Amageddon. Und das ist live passiert. Einen Film, den du bestimmt schon geguckt hast, du hast den Film geguckt, guckst du lieber die Geschichte an, wo man sich denkt, krass, wenn das mal passiert, und dann passiert es und du guckst Dota 2. Ja, ja. Was habe ich alles schon verpasst in meinem Leben? Hol mal den Kopf aus dem Sand. Ja, du hast recht. Wir müssen auch mal, wir brauchen mal so einen Überblick, so was wir alles verpasst haben, was ist mit dem Bernsteinzimmer, was ist mit Atlantis, ist Troja immer noch, ist Troja mittlerweile gefunden oder irgendwie sowas, können wir da mal irgendwie einfach mal gucken, ist die Basics so. Wir brauchen die Basics, wir müssen den Kopf aus dem Sand stecken und in die Sonne blänzeln und der Wahrheit ins Augenlicht sehen. Wäre das nicht eine App, dass du sagst, mich interessieren folgende Themen. Bernsteinzimmer, Asteroidenangriffe, Atlantis, Troja. Und dann so Status Quo. Genau, Status Quo und immer wenn neue Artikel zu genau diesen Themen rauskommen, will ich genau die. Gibt's? Alles andere interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Ja, wie so ein sehr konzentriertes Reddit eigentlich, ne?
Ja, ja.
Ja, gibt's ein Troja-Reddit?
So Sub-Sub-Sub-Sub-Themen.
Gibt's ein Troja-Reddit, wo die echt nochmal im Kucken im Sand,
wo das ist? Ist das ein Problem, Troja
zu finden? Ja, ich glaube, es wurde schon Troja gefunden,
aber es ist so, ja, ist es das wirklich
und so, weiß man nicht genau.
Es gibt ja noch so ein paar Orte, die noch nicht gefunden sind.
Also Bernsteinzimmer bin ich dabei. Dieser Zug, dieser krasse Zug. Atlantis, bist du dabei? Atlantis bin ich dabei, Nessie, würde ich auch noch aufhalten. Ja, Nessie kann man auch aufhalten. Bigfoot, der Yeti, Sasquatch bin ich auch noch dabei. Das finde ich ein gutes Thema. Und dann der Wedding-Knall, den würde ich auch noch mit draufschreiben. Da ist ja auch dierichtlager recht mau. In Wedding gab es ja einige Knalls. Ja, war so spannend, dass, ich gucke nochmal nach, wie viele, ach, niemand danach geholfen hat, das aufzuklären. Naja, gut. Wir halten euch auf jeden Fall weiter auf dem Laufenden, dies jede Woche und, oh mein Gott, ein riesiger Meteorit fliegt auf uns zu. Oh nein, heben wir schnell ab! Das Podcast-Ufe muss schnell abhe word, it's a worst production.